you've just mentioned there that two
black holes could meet what's that event
like we've never observed an event like
that so we do have the ligo experiment
and the Virgo experiment on Earth right
now that are detecting gravitational
waves from the Stellar Mass black holes
that form from Supernova when two black
holes are coming together and merging
they're spiraling around each other at
incredible speeds and curving and
uncurving space as they go past to
extreme amounts and so they send ripples
out into space when this happens and the
biggest of those ripples happens when
they finally come together and merge and
we actually are able to detect that we
literally watch the distance between two
mirrors where you've got a laser firing
back and forth measuring the distance
between them very very accurately change
by less than the width of an atom we see
that and we can detect that okay well
something just merged in the universe
over there so hopefully I can answer
your question maybe in 2040 or so but
you can imagine it's probably a very
cataclysmic event when it does happen